by the power of castle hate school i am
hella mark harley and you are watching
the world's number one rated fitness
adjacent podcast now there might be
other fitness podcasts out there that
are strictly fitness but here at the
haters will say podcast we are fitness
adjacent we'll touch on fitness we'll
touch on some boobs we'll touch on some
dogs but guess what we'll also touch on
other stuff related to fitness that's
not quite fitness but could be related
to fitness if you really think about it
and go like a you know six degrees of
kevin bacon type thing okay
then it we're all still related to
fitness and it's adjacent to that right
so today oh my god we have one of the
greatest episodes i think i've ever done
for you we're going to talk about my
recent adventures in northern california
we're going to talk about of course the
liver king and his many adventures on
the east coast we're going to talk about
some steroids
shocker i know i'm going to tell you
about my first cycle and also a cycle
i'm thinking about doing i want to run
it by you because you guys are all
anabolic experts at this point
oh we're gonna look at some i got a lot
of this is why we can't have nice gyms
lined up who knows if we'll get to all
of them i got a really cool hella sick
fitness page to show you
this guy's a beast and you know what we
got some some more hella sick hella sad
fitness tragedies it's a new recurring
segment but i want to give it you know i
want to inspire you guys but i also want
to give you that really real i want to
make sure that uh
we look at some of the realities of the
fitness world as a fitness adjacent
podcast you know tragedy is often
adjacent to fitness what am i doing to
my computer right now well that is
talcum powder that was in
my backpack that exploded uh during
a trip to sacramento exploded might be a
strong word uh
mark left the talcum powder open in his
backpack might be a more accurate term
but
yes you know i was almost uh almost
didn't make my flight to sacramento went
to
uh the shows up there
with brendan the gang and uh
i couldn't find my id and so i wasted
all this time looking for my id and then
i was like well if i don't leave right
this moment i'm going to be late and
miss my flight for sure turns out if you
guys didn't know this
you know i don't only drop fitness
advice and tips i also drop real life
tips turns out you don't need an id to
get in a plane you just kind of need to
do like an extra security check right
they will take out all of your stuff and
individually swipe it one by one and
then put it back in your bag and that
may take up some extra time that may
cause you to miss your flight but let's
just say i was the latest i've ever been
for a flight and still made it you know
i sat down and like three minutes later
we're flying so
made it it was awesome brendan's usual
uh crew of openers couldn't make it so i
got to meet some new friends up in
sacramento at the punchline
shout out craig conant if you don't know
him the dude is hotlarius and
just a really interesting guy really
open about his past uh
you know
drug use and experience as a former
addict i'm not selling him out this is
part of his act folks okay but i always
love talking to
addicts who have their
stuff in check now because you know
usually they have a lot of funny stories
and a lot of interesting perspective on
life and the people that they used to
hang out with and and what drugs and
addiction uh can make you do or the ways
in which it alters your behavior and
mindset so anything when you've been
through something like that and seen
that and recovered from it i don't know
i just i think those tend to be very
interesting people and when you can spin
that into comedy i know that the crowd
really had a strong reaction to him he
sold a lot of merch it was just really
cool to uh you know see somebody work
who i hadn't i've been aware of and i
think we'd followed each other for a
little while but i didn't know he was
going to be on this trip so that was
really cool in addition to that i was
able to go to my
older brother's 40th birthday this is
the same brother that i got the car from
in rhode island he for his 40th birthday
came out to
uh california to where most of my family
lives in northern california and we did
like a
40th birthday celebration at a local
tavern called the hop monk tavern
catered with street tacos
uh and you know local
beers etc so i had some interesting
beers
yes i drink sometimes guys i know it's
hard to believe
uh given that i'm negative three percent
body fat year round but the fact is yes
once every six years i will have an
alcoholic beverage um or 18 you know
somebody actually commented on my they
saw me in sacramento and they were like
hey man i saw you in sacramento your
eyes were all bloodshot and you look
super [ __ ] up i said what's up i said
hey hella mark harley and you said
that's me
now was i really you know
was i uh drunk from
or messed up or did i have bloodshot
eyes from alcohol consumption or the
fact that it might have been like 1am
after a show i don't know but what i do
have respect for going to these shows
and doing nothing having literally zero
responsibilities is
it is a grind you do stay up late you
know doing
two shows just being up that late as an
old geezer like myself like i'm just i
don't usually stay up past 10 p.m so
being forced to stay up till
one or whatever and uh it gives you
empathy for comics doing late shows and
somebody like brendan doing meet and
greets after the show keeping up that
social energy after doing an hour on
stage it's a lot
so
got to see my family kill two birds with
one stone so sick hitch to ride back
from my aunt and uncle that i don't get
to see too often who live in sacramento
and uh you know some other really
interesting news this is gonna be the
first link that i click on in a second
here i'm just gonna set it up that uh
i'm next
we know the uh like the 17th i think
16th is the i'm going to fly out the
15th to oklahoma city
we're going to shoot on the 16th and i'm
going to fly back the 17th what am i
doing for this shoot i am shooting a
hanson music video yeah you heard it
right hanson remember
now i'm about to make history in case
you didn't know as the only person to
ever be in two handsome music videos you
heard it right in 2013
i was in my first hanson music video
it's called get the girl back a shot at
the i think it's called like the
satellite or something in silver lake
some um a little concert venue small
concert venue and uh it was really cool
because they were like they were doing a
live performance and my little bit role
was uh they had people
as this guy's like going to find this
girl and like
you know he's encountering different
people
at this concert and we're like saying
individual lines so my role in this in
this video was uh you know just a few
seconds
but i got to
say a line from the song and i thought
it turned out well so can we play that
real quick
show her
that you're not like all the rest just
nailed it god like ah
that's when i'm like dude i could really
do this
if i can be in a handsome music video i
can do almost anything um
so i am actually psyched for that i've
talked to the director and it's gonna be
a really funny concept
using my muscles
and also
my comedy
perfect combination so yesterday i also
had a visit from my buddy nash from
repworks who i have brought up on this
podcast before repworks is a really cool
page it's an instagram page right now he
also offers
coaching and programs so you can for
example i used his deadlift program to
put like 90 pounds on my deadlift this
past year it was really awesome i loved
the workouts they're very specific
but easy to follow
uh you know his person he gives you
percentages of your max he gives you uh
you know exact rest times um so he flew
out to from chicago just for the day to
shoot some vlog content that we're
hopefully going to upload on the next
couple weeks here uh doing like a
deadlift and back workout and it's just
it's similar to something you would see
on his uh on the rep works instagram
page because he puts daily workouts on
there
um you know with just an a b and c a
main mover uh some back off work and and
some accessory work so what we did was
worked up to like a heavy single i
haven't done dead lifts in forever me
and the crew kind of have it me
chappelle like we were doing heavy
deadlifts for a while and then didn't do
them um because we all kind of had like
you know brendan had his hamstring
injury i had a lower back injury uh
chappelle has a punk band that he
prioritizes over us sometimes so it all
works out
no
so i got up to 500 pounds for single
felt good because again i hadn't done
deadlifts in a while but i wanted to see
if i could was still in that ballpark um
and then we did some back off work uh of
with deficit deadlifts and that brings
me
to a bro science academy i'm going to
talk about deficit deadlifts here
because i think it's something that
i hadn't really done before and nash is
a big proponent of deficit deadlifts and
so i started doing them with his program
and i've come to really like them for a
few different reasons so i worked up to
a heavy single 500 then i backed down to
315 uh for three sets of 12. now the
benefit to me of doing these deficit
deadlifts and when i say deficit i just
mean i'm standing on a plate so we were
i was standing on a 55 pound bumper
plate so
it's you know maybe if you stacked like
two normal 45 pound plates together that
like are uh steel plates
it would be about the equivalent you
know so like it's probably like six
inches off the ground but
what that does just providing a little
bit more room to go down um
it involves your quads a little bit more
because it forces you to get down to to
like more of a squat position right you
can't use quite as much weight so 315
might be
a little bit easy for me normally if you
know for doing uh you know sets of that
nature but
uh
just that that lat that final six inches
going down to the floor and coming back
up engages the quads and the legs forces
you to keep a certain balance in your
form that you might not have um you know
it's much harder to like lean forward
and get off balance four because you
have to come down into a deeper squat
position
and keep it balanced the entire time and
what it does is take pressure off of
your lower back so as somebody who's
been experiencing lower back pain
and lower back injuries lower back
strain i still even though i'm mostly
recovered like i still have this chronic
um you know pain that i'm this is there
most of the day now have i done an
amazing job of like really stretching it
out and finding like you know i have to
get like you know my psoas stretched out
and these different things i don't know
if that's going to be it but your psoas
connects your upper body to your lower
body it's really hard to get at so i'm
like experimenting with ways to get at
this hip pain uh-huh have you seen the
so right product i have it i just
haven't like used it yeah but it looks
like it digs like way in you know but it
is like
you know you're like oh i this thing but
i can't like you know you kind of do
need to like stick something in there
right
have you used it
uh yeah my brother shane uh has like
chronically tight so as yeah he use it
and again i assume it's that but because
it's so deep inside like you know it's
like not really my back it like starts
there but then it's like oh this feels
like
if i were to like drill into the middle
of my hip it'd be in there and i think
that's
where it is but he swears by it
uh yeah
i'll take his word for it then he also
works for the so right he's sponsored by
them um no i will you know like so i'm
looking into stuff like that but it was
nice to know that at least doing you
know going up to 500 pounds i didn't
feel anything extra and in fact the
workout that he put us through
afterwards doing uh we did some seal
rows and by that i mean like a chest
supported but free weight row because
sometimes like a t-bar row is a chest
supported
machine row
um but a seal row is like usually you
have to stack up
benches uh to get high enough off the
ground where you you know if you extend
your arms all the way down you can have
it a barbell or dumbbells under there
and you can pull up straight into your
back but at zoo they have this
particular machine
that allows a chest supported free
weight row where you're like you know
hanging your you can come down and uh
towards the floor
we did some of that we did some strict
pull-ups um
and we also did
some
uh uh reverse hypers right where you're
you're laying it's also chest and
stomach supported and your legs hang
down joe rogan if you listen to him he
always talks about this and i've never
really done it because it's kind of an
awkward movement but this time we like
to get your feet under there i like i
just didn't like it didn't click for me
this time it did because we didn't use
any weight
and even just hanging off and letting
your legs come down like this i see that
it's better than a hamstring stretch for
your lower back because the weight of
gravity like pulls
the lower half of your body down and i
feel like it got at something perhaps
even my psoas but i felt that stretching
something inside that joint um
where your upper body meets your lower
body where you know uh
your you know
right around your waist what is that
like the
cervical spine meets your lumbar spine i
guess um
it was tugging on something and kind of
stretching it out that bottom resting
position that i just had never felt
before so it's like oh this is the magic
of the reverse hyper i want to start
doing those more
and after doing a couple sets of them i
actually felt relief in that area
came back a few hours later but in that
moment
i did feel relief so
i'm going to urge you guys to check out
deficit deadlifts do your deadlifts keep
good form and just elevate yourself uh
by you know six inches or so
and especially if you have back problems
you'll see that you can get this fatigue
on your legs and also your traps like
any time i do
you know i forget about this when you do
heavy deadlifts it really is one of the
best trap workouts because
you know traps
shrugs are great but just holding a
weight
with that static tension you know a
super heavy weight it does work your
traps because your traps are working
overtime to like
not let your scapula fall off your body
so
in that sense you know it's one of the
best trap workouts and i always feel it
up and down you know not just
like the the top portion of my traps the
lower traps as well the middle traps all
right let's take a break from me talking
about super cool interesting stuff to
tell you about happy hippo hippocratum
once again
this is the product that i use a few
times a week now i'm on it right now
during this podcast can you believe it i
try to save it so
it's a product i can use to get myself
into that really focused zone where i'm
feeling good and my brain is greased up
and working well i don't know how else
to describe it but i'd liken it to you
know
somewhere between a nicotine and an
adderall but again it's all natural it's
an all-natural product that comes from a
leaves of a plant from southeast asia it
is the best focused product i've ever
used straight up uh because it doesn't
take me too far in that stimulant
direction doesn't take me too far in
that relaxation direction it works
somewhere in the middle and just makes
me feel good so
the best part of it all is it's high
quality product right
happy hippo is a brand that you can
trust as far as you know what's in the
product there's many uh other kratom
products out there that i personally
wouldn't trust and i know how this works
because i'm somebody who orders random
stuff on the internet you don't always
know what you're buying but when you go
to happy hippo you can trust that
they are delivering the product that
they state they are going to and it has
the highest quality ingredients so if
you visit
happyhippoherbles.com and use promo code
thick boy you're going to get 20
off each and every order you place
that's happyhippo herbals.com
thick boy with three c's at checkout get
20 off and see
if you can relate to what i'm talking
about as far as this product
making your brain go
[Music]
let's go okay
as promised boy oh boy we got some good
liver king memes of the week you know we
always start out with a regular post
from him the liver king takes over new
york this week i was surprised to say oh
he's got a subway going on what are we
going to see
let's roll this
uh-huh as expected he's got the chains
he's got the kettlebells he's got the
uh i was gonna say anka wakes doesn't
look like he has ankle weights maybe um
but he's coming out of a subway so this
too like he flew to new york and he's
just like hey let's get on a subway with
80 pounds of chains and two super like
the kettlebells are not small he looks
like they're they're at least 60 pounds
it would not surprise me if they were 80
pound kettlebells but he's uh traveling
on the subway at least one stop you know
except but he got a in the car ahead of
him and you know i just i appreciate the
planning that goes into this like he's
taking his family to new york and he's
like i'm just gonna wear my shorts and
no shirt and it's like okay it's march
in new york it must be cold i'll have to
look at the weather in a second but i
can't imagine that it's like a warm out
you know but uh there he is red chested
and full of chains kettlebells
and uh his trademark hat let's do the
the next one this is what's even more
egregious oh [ __ ] this is a not the one
i was thinking of but we can play this
it's still this is funny
can we play the volume one more time
takes one royal ship every morning just
like clockwork at 6 30. and guess what
i'm here
so he's going to the royal
show he's talking about pooping yeah
i thought this was like i'm like this
can't be him doing it
did somebody use a deep fake but he
takes the poop comes out
liver king out there we go out and it's
just a giant ribeye
that actually made me laugh a lot okay
and you know what we'll save the other
one for next week but uh it's another
new york adventure okay and then this is
the liver king meme of the week this is
like a playing card right
it's like
the liver king legitimately makes me
laugh more than anything else i think um
is both his videos and these memes so
it's blood pressure one thousand out of
the thousands like ranking all his
strengths you know like they used to
have these like the x-men cards that i
would collect as a kid maybe you guys
did too moral integrity question mark
chances he eats that stuff zero redness
90 nattiness come on bro
[Laughter]
oh a clever one and i'm gonna give a
shout out to the guy who looks like he
made it um
cillo connor c-i-l-l-o
uh connor
is this at
so good job if you made that
all right
we're gonna do a help i'm on steroids
i've been promising to tell you guys
about the first time i ever took
steroids and the mistakes that i make
and the
message and
lessons that i hope to pass on to other
people who are going to take similar
compounds or doing this for the first
time now i spent a couple years when i
was like 18. i must have been
cognizant of the fact that i wanted to
take steroids at least interested in it
and maybe there are a lot of people out
there who never end up taking steroids
who start to
research it right so i don't know if i
was like set on taking it there's also
these questions of uh how do you get
this stuff so i would go on this website
called
this is in like 2000 the year 2000 2001
so
you know it was the beginning of web
popularity i guess i'd say and i've been
on the internet of course for a number
of years but like
this was like this version the version
of the dark web back then was like a pay
website called it was steroid
encyclopedia.com but they spelled
encyclopedia
in the british way where it's like
encyclopaedia p-a-e-d-i-a or something
like that
um so they should have spelled it like
encyclopedia like cycle like a cycle of
animals that's a good one yeah that
would have been the ultimate uh you know
cyclopedia
steroid and cycle
steroids story
um
steroid and steroid cyclopedia
so you would go on there you could pay
like 20 bucks for an access to
these stereo distributors and you'd get
their contact information and i suppose
you would
like email them now i'm trying to think
like how did i even get in touch with
them i don't know but like how it ended
up was i'd send envelopes of cash to
these people in different countries or
moneygram or western union but like i
remember you try to do western union
online and they'd be like you cannot
send this money to this person so like
i'd have to do it in person but a couple
times i did actually send envelopes of
cash i remember going to the
uh post office in claremont california
and handing like a thousand dollars in
cash it was all like small bills so it
was like this thick wad of cash and the
woman's like what's in here and i'm like
pictures
like i didn't make any intent like i
didn't even like double bag it or like
put a piece of paper on it you know 18
year old dumbass um
but also
you know so i got some stuff there i
think i bought like
deca and winstrol and uh dball from this
online
uh vendor and it came through like i
actually never had you know over the
years i ordered for for me and my
friends i did a few cycles in college
and then stopped completely for the next
like 13 or 14 years and didn't get back
on trt until i was like 35. um
so you know
again
in case you're thinking like the mark's
been blasting steroids for like you know
most of his life i did some cycles
went natty i'll never be like actually
like all netty lifetime nettie you know
even if i stop right now but
um you know i i just had some it's
interesting to see like what you go back
and revisit like what i was thinking i i
thought that my dosages were mild and
i'll get to what they were in a second
but like
you know
in retrospect that could have gotten so
much off of so little and and took too
much i also will just say i went to i
went to uh
rosarito mexico with a group of people
and bought like sustanon from the local
pharmacy and like i just did it so
brazenly like i don't know what i was
saying it's like was like with my
friends i'm like i'm gonna go buy
steroids in this [ __ ] like you know
um
in this uh pharmacia you know and i was
like
testosterone
um
you know i probably tried to speak
spanish and they were like yeah you want
juice okay um but they brought me the
testosterone almost like part of me
because i could have gotten it online i
think i just wanted to like see
does this work can you actually do it
you know you're like oh my god like can
i go to amsterdam and actually have sex
with a prostitute um
because i could have gotten the stuff i
just bought it yeah and it was cheap and
you can go in and just get this uh get
this stuff over the counter um
but
i heard people with me like judge me
like i don't think that's right you know
like i don't want you girls are always
like i don't want you to take steroids
um because i was with my girlfriend and
her friends at the time and some other
people i don't know what they were
thinking i just didn't care like i just
was like oh i'm set on doing this so you
can sizzle my dizzle if you don't like
it so
my first cycle ended up being
uh
sustained on 250 a week one cc a week
the deca that i took was 300 milligrams
so i was taking 300 milligrams a week
and then like a kickstart of a month of
you know four to five weeks of dianaball
30 milligrams a day i am like in a month
i gained like 25 pounds you know and i
was also eating
tons of food and training really hard
you know like i did i was doing like a
six day a week split hitting every
muscle group um i was doing you know
bodybuilder split of like
back and triceps and then chest and
biceps so like i was doing antagonistic
muscles on the on the same
day and probably getting you know like
so if you're doing back and biceps on
separate days you're really hitting him
like four days a week but i just
remember like i looked really big and i
was very obvious to anybody looking at
me like oh that guy's on steroids uh not
necessarily because i looked like ripped
or vascular but just because i gained so
much weight and it was more of a puffy
look that i think i got and that was
like another mistake that i realized i'm
like oh you're taking all these
steroids that are known for retaining
water even though you go online and
everything's like take this like if you
want to bulk or gain weight take this
and that
um
and i used to think nandrollon would
make you retain a ton of water now that
i've taken it on its own that's really
not the case i think it's a combination
of testosterone and nandrollone and
people would talk about prolactin with
android i haven't experienced any
prolactin side effects even taking a
high dose of dandrulin on its own but
apparently if you combine the two
there are some effects that i wouldn't
necessarily say are worth it and also
i've talked about the finasteride issue
before that you can take finasteride on
testosterone it blocks the conversion of
test into dht but when you're taking
nangalone uh nandralone is actually a
it converts into a more safe a hair safe
steroid so if you take finasteride with
it it prevents that conversion and keeps
more of the nandrollon and angelone in
and of itself is
uh like it binds to the hair follicle
and causes hair loss so like you want
that conversion so if you're taking them
both it puts you in a weird spot where
like you'd block the conversion of
testosterone into dht but not like you
want the nangelone to convert uh into
its uh you know five alpha reductase
product
and uh that doesn't happen so it ends up
being worse for your hair and the
combination of test and deca from what i
understand actually increases your
prolactin levels on its own it doesn't
do that and then dianaball is also a
test derivative and so
you know as i learn more and more you
can actually like there's many people
out there who use
dianaball as a test base because you
want something that aromatizes so you
have some sort of estrogen in your body
you want a little bit of estrogen you
want
the neuroprotective and cardioprotective
effects of an estradiol
and
that happens with with dball if you're
using both test and anabolic you're
getting all this estrogen conversion so
maybe that's not the best combination
but i just remember i was very watery i
remember i took a flight to see my
girlfriend
and like got the worst uh edema in my
ankles on the flight like you know so
i'm retaining all this water i'm big
strong and puffy but like you know
nobody looks good with uh puffy ankles
right that you could like stick your
finger into and uh you know go an inch
deep and
and have that imprint in there it's
disgusting it's nasty uh and just a
little bit of pressure
change in the cabin of the airplane i
guess caused that you know staying up
uh you know because it was like a
red-eye flight to see her so
all in all i gained like
30 pounds you know got up to like
let's see i probably put 60 pounds in my
bench press
you know 50 60 pounds of my squat um
could clean 315 with the most atrocious
form of all time
but
in retrospect it was really obvious oh
also i got like
like somewhere along the line like i was
finding like
i started getting acne after like a
month or something like like some of the
worst back acne i've ever had it was
terrible and then it's like
you know
great you you take steroids and work out
to look good and then you don't want to
take your shirt off you know so that was
probably one of the worst elements of it
and i also had this bright idea
of getting i'm like oh like in
anticipation of getting acne i'm going
to get
anti-bacterial stuff um what do they
call them
what is uh
what is oh antibiotics yeah so i like
bought mexican antibiotics to like and
just started taking them like from the
get-go like the stupidest idea ever um
that i don't think you know so it's like
destroying my gut bacteria i assume and
also
you know just
like
it's throwing whatever is going on in
your body off balance so i assume like
maybe like if you take a course of them
and then stop picking them like it's
gonna rebound you know because all the
like super bacteria are still living in
your body i don't know uh but all i know
is like i took them and then stopped and
then it got like wait like i got this
you know the worst acne on my back that
i've ever gotten from any cycle i
haven't experienced that um to any
degree you know even close since then
but it was just
so because of that i would have you know
i looked back and i would have done many
things differently i maybe would have
taken one of the three things that i was
taking
i probably would have just started with
the 250 test a week and done a longer
cycle and just
experimented one by one because you
really don't know what each thing is
going to do inside your body you i can't
tell you if it was the deck if it was
the test if it was the d-ball that was
causing you know any of the water
retention on its own because if you
start off with three compounds
you know you can't isolate the side
effects of any of them so
if you're out there listening to this
i would take literally if you wanted if
any of those compounds sound interesting
to you do one of them
and run it you know for a certain amount
of time and and see what the side
effects are start at the minimum
effective dose then you know gauge from
there
and uh
let's see yeah oh also
for this
coming music video i was gonna i'm just
about done with my nand dralon cycle i'm
thinking i was had a plan of going back
on just regular old trt but then i get
cast in the music video where they're
gonna use me with my shirt off and i'm
like
should i take tren winstrol mastron and
primo that i have on hand for no reason
you know for like two weeks and just
blast the [ __ ] out of that for the you
know so i'm currently debating that part
of me wants to do it there are all these
compounds and i'm like oh they're
terrible for your hair they're terrible
for your liver but two weeks you know i
could just handle a weekend of partying
right and then you know it'll be my last
hurrah so that's what i'm currently
thinking about
by the time i do my next episode you'll
know what i have decided okay let's do
another this is why we can't have ice
creams i have a bunch of links here
let's see how they go okay first of all
yeah this guy's uh let's crank the
volume up on that yep he's saying how do
you how do you spot somebody in the
squad this guy looks buff obviously he
knows what he's doing
so we're setting that up
reasonable distance uh-huh
uh-huh take a big step back
everything's looking good yeah and just
grab those cheeks
uh-huh
[Music]
so he says if you start to struggle
you start to tickle his ball sick and
shove your thumb off his ass now
that is meant to be funny but somehow i
feel like that would actually work you
know if uh if somebody's tickling my
ball sack and shoving their thumb up my
ass at the bottom of a squat i think i
might get a sudden burst of inspiration
let's check out that next video
okay this is uh this is a classic
spotting
screw-up
um this guy's i think if those are 25
pound plates and 45s he's got 245's and
three 25s on each i think it's like 375
around that ballpark like high 300s
so this guy looks like a rando that he
asked to spot at the gym
comes down on the bench comes up it's
he's struggling but it's still moving he
stalls out and the guy grabs it then he
lets go and it goes back to his chest
and he's like
god damn it he has to dump it because
the guy's like not cognizant enough of
like what's going on to then just like
lift it all the way up
now
uh the guy lifting was very frustrated
and i listened to the video earlier and
he's like you know dude you can't touch
it i was still moving and my friends
would come to me with stuff like this
i'd be like oh my god i was at the gym
and like this guy touched the bar like
i'm like but why would you have a
stranger spot you like if it's that
important to you
don't have somebody spot you you know
because you can dump the bar as he
already did he did it at the end of the
move anyway you know if you're gonna
dump it anyway potentially if you don't
have clips on there what's the point
just don't have a spotter you know
uh because i just see this so often the
guys get super pissed off and it's like
well you just recruited a stranger to
come spot you like and they're scared to
that you're gonna die into the bar you
know so of course they're gonna be like
quick on the trigger to spot you unless
you sit there and coach them for five
minutes like don't under any
circumstances touch the bar unless it's
traveling back towards my neck and i
tell you i can't breathe and i start to
turn blue like you know you have to give
people this like hierarchy of and then
still you could still communicate that
to somebody and they're going to freak
out seeing 400 pounds like shaking in
your hands so
uh my suggestion is don't use a spotter
on bench press
if you're that
you know high level that you can bench
almost 400 pounds you know what you're
doing at that point just be smart about
it
okay another one
this is just one of these so he's you
know psyched for hitting 315 and he's on
the smith machine i think the first
one's a um
serious and the second one's a joke i
could be wrong they could both be jokes
but this guy's on the smith machine
hitting 315 and he barely goes down and
just his form in general makes me think
like the way his knees come forward and
buckle and he's like looks really skinny
the second guy looks like he has decent
squat form and is much more self-aware
of
the bar movement and i think he's like
mocking the first one but
this is something you see a lot where
it's like hey why put on 315 on the
smith machine and go you know four
inches down i just wonder you know again
i want to interview these people and be
like what what makes you think that
that's a squat what makes you think that
uh you know you're going all the way
down or in your head are you going down
to parallel or what not that it's doing
nothing
but
how did that guy put on three plates and
not realize that he can't do one plate
all the way down i don't know like why
do you keep going and the lesson for you
is ego lifting of course you can do so
much
with so little if you can control the
weight and i'm continuing to prove that
point to myself because of course i
eagle lift as well but you know for
example i did a bench press workout
today with brendan and i only went up to
275
you know and by controlling it by using
a narrow grip by pausing it by using a
really solid bar path and just focusing
you get a tremendous workout with you
know a minimum i would do my working
sets at 3 15 before so i'm taking a huge
chunk of weight off but i'm getting just
the same if not better workouts by
letting the ego go and saying i'm not
defined by the weights that i lift
which is easier said than done when
you're a narcissistic egomaniac who
defines himself by the size of his
muscles
okay and final one here
this is another spot fail and again this
guy oh this guy's so big and strong and
i haven't seen how many like it looks
like it's over 400 i'm i'm loosely
saying that
looks at least like 365 but i can't see
if there's a fourth plate on there the
main thing is he recruits this
commercial gym trainer and of course
most commercial gym trainers don't know
what the f they're doing in the gym
but this guy is particularly agree just
because he spots at the elbows on a
barbell bench press now
i think
there's a time and a place to spot at
the elbows um like
a shoulder press like a dumbbell
shoulder press or even a a dumbbell
bench press the danger is though on a
dumbbell bench press for example if you
lift at the elbows the person's forearm
can collapse inward and i've had that
happen like while i'm spotting somebody
like their arm collapsed inwards and
like if they didn't move their face out
of the way it would have hit them right
so there is a danger i prefer to spot at
the wrists you need to use more force
because you have to like
you know grab with your fingers and lead
their wrists up but it eliminates that
danger
this guy puts
he like causes the guy to go off balance
and have the things uh
all the ways come off but again that's
what you get if you're spotting somebody
if you're recruiting someone to spot you
and you don't know them and you don't
know
with their knowledge level
disasters like that are always going to
happen all right i think that's it right
um let's move on to this hella sick
fitness page it's a guy named tom
haviland i don't know how to turn that
off on my computer it's the most
annoying sound of the world someday i'll
figure it out um but okay awesome
christian's coming through in the clutch
to teach me how to use my computer
because i'm an old man now
this guy i think he lives in australia
i'm going to read his uh the bio real
quick the tx extreme power building
program coaching and jailhouse strong
apparel links below um
now
this guy like doesn't show his face for
some reason maybe he's like a total ugg
out um
but okay the dude is giant like the
dude's like six eight let's say some of
and and his training goals seem to be
like just get as big and strong it's
almost like he's trying to be some like
super soldier right he does all these
like he does conventional lifts with
massive amounts of weights but he also
does like
farmers walks and like like he'll post
like the unconventional lift of the day
and it's like you know him doing uh like
a clean into like a zercher squad you
know what is he doing here
just i just wanted to see what it is oh
okay yeah yeah that right that's the
only thing that shows his face so here
he's doing like a really heavy curl uh
just from his knees if we could go back
to some of the other ones um like at the
top there's one okay yeah so he's doing
like a 900 pound deadlift in the first
one
um
and i think he lives on like a ranch in
australia if i'm not mistaken um
like everything he does is outside he's
got these really cool implements set up
out there
you know he's trying to get to 400
pounds it's interesting to see
the diet that he uses because it's like
really when you're trying to gain weight
it's about getting in
calories from carbohydrates so you know
he's eating like a thousand grams of
carbohydrates a day possibly more
up to ten thousand eight to ten thousand
calories a day from some of the the days
that i've seen him diet um if we could
go to that he has this little
military press implement if you get like
where he's seated right there
yeah there we go
so it's like
it's welded on you know the bar is
welded on um
but
i think i saw him doing here he is
repping at least three plates maybe more
um but i've seen him do like
four yeah 357 for for
five i think it says
um yep and i've seen him do like a max
of like 450 which is just insane like a
seated press of 450 pounds if we go up a
little bit he also does like
explosive training there's i think the
second video on his page
um
there we go yeah
it's like a 400 pound clean actually i
think he's got five plates in there
he does it he like cleans it into his
like like so he has to let go and then
put it into the crook of his arm for a
zercher squat which is like where you're
carrying it in in your arms and then
squatting all the way down it's just
bananas because the way he you know he's
he starts at three plates and then works
his way up but he just throws this
weight around so
what i'm saying is
the guy is just inspirational because
he's like
no nonsense like he doesn't like even
take his shirt off like everything's
like he's like training in these like
dicky pants you know like he's training
in work pants and work boots and doing
these like farmers carries with farmers
equipment like it looks like a like a
tractor um
wheel or something whatever's on the
inside like you know he's doing like a
hex bar
uh dead lift into farmer's walk with
this like big tractor
gear
and uh so i just like the approach which
is no nonsense no frills just lifting
extremely heavy weight been still in a
very safe controlled fashion so there's
not a lot of like ego lifting because
he's so incredibly strong he can handle
all these weights but he's really
pushing himself
in these
extreme
um
you know
these
with these extreme
lifts and also doing athletic [ __ ] too
or like picking stuff up and throwing it
on here it's kind of a strong man move
he also like will jump on stuff that's
super high you're like oh this dude's
like six eight 380 and also has like a
40 inch vertical um it's insane so check
it out his at is tom havilland
h-a-v-i-l-a-n-d
tom underscore havaland on instagram
and it's just something like i've never
seen anybody like this before so really
cool
let's get on to a hella sat fitness
tragedy more played some more dates and
some other people made posts about this
guy but i'm gonna read more plates more
dates
post about this guy who passed away
recently
i was unaware of this guy um obviously
he had a really good physique really
ripped he looks like he's possibly in
his early twenties gauging uh just by
this picture
rest in peace scott murray here's a
summation of what his regiment looked
like he maintained around five percent
body fat year-round natty and was
burning roughly 5
500 calories per day that's a lot
his workouts would typically burn about
1400 calories each workout would result
in his hand shaking and feeling sick but
he still took no days off i believe
someone mentioned he hadn't taken a rest
day in years he was sleeping around
three to four hours per night and would
use those extra hours that should have
been sleeping to go take long walks to
get steps in and burn more calories i
hadn't heard of him until my subreddit
started posting about his passing
yesterday after doing a bit of digging i
found out that scott was a mpmd
subscriber and he had sent me a few
messages in the past based on what was
mentioned at the funeral it sounds like
scott had the all-sleep when a dead
mentality ingrained in his mind and had
some serious mental health issues that
caused him to take this to the extreme
this can serve as a learning opportunity
for the fitness community as a whole i
have never in my life seen a case of an
individual that literally exercised so
hard and under slept so much that their
heart gave out
one thing i can relate to is the lack of
sleep as it was only a handful of years
ago that i was intentionally pulling an
all-nighter once a week to get more work
done
one thing i eventually realized is that
the all sleep when i'm dead hardcore
work ethic mentality that was
perpetuated by entrepreneurs was not
only extremely unhealthy but actually
counterproductive entirely as the hours
you were working under slept would yield
a fraction of the quality of work you
would get done if you otherwise just got
a full night of sleep
work smarter not harder couldn't agree
more with that sentiment
there's a few things to unpack here i
would say you know we see some of these
examples of obsessive behavior in
fitness
when you get stuck on this notion that
you have to do a certain amount every
day you have to work out till you puke
or you have to you know get 30 000 steps
in or you have to be at a certain body
fat percentage tristan lee kind of
opened up about this recently and talked
about kind of you know obsessively
maintaining this four to five percent
body fat year round and what he'd have
to do obsessing over steps obsessing
over each individual calorie
i think it's with people who are
pursuing excellence there's a fine line
between these two things where it's like
yeah like to get things done and get
things right it is it does pay to be
meticulous and detail-oriented but then
you can easily take it uh to a really
unhealthy extreme so
i would just caution anybody from
you know if if your
exercise habits are cutting into your
sleep even if your pro productivity is
cutting into your sleep on a consistent
basis we know that sleep is so important
and that it's you know people who sleep
three to four hours a night um there's
many famous cases like you know ronald
reagan and um
the who's a british prime minister um
the iron lady
her name's escaping me now because i
also have dementia but she uh
you know
she would sleep three to four hours a
night these all you know yes the iron
lady
who is that margaret thatcher that's it
um
these people
suffer from dementia and alzheimer's
later in life because they
uh you know
the
science behind it is
the sewage system of your brain can't
function properly you're receiving low
level damage simply by being awake and
looking into light right it causes this
damage to your brain that can be
repaired with healthy sleep but if you
don't get healthy sleep every night
that the plaque that accumulates cannot
be
cleaned out and over the course of years
and years and years if you keep up that
habit uh that is what directly leads to
dementia and alzheimer's and there's a
lot of anecdotal evidence and that's
kind of like the theory i'm not saying
it's like
exactly proven but when you when you
listen to these sleep experts they're
like
dude like it's just nothing is worth you
know compromising your sleep and and and
the idea that there's these outliers
that are like oh well i only need three
to four hours of sleep it's total bs
apparently like there's no there's
they've never proven any single
individual who functions as well on
three to four hours of sleep as anybody
else does on seven to nine
um
and your perception of your own
productivity on
uh small amounts of sleep like you think
you're doing okay it's kind of like
drunk driving you think you're driving
fine but in fact if
you're able to measure this objectively
you're not at all but there's a range in
which you know maybe okay if you get
three hours of sleep you can tell that
you're not functioning well but at like
five or six you think you're functioning
as well as seven to eight but it turns
out that you're not by any uh objective
measurement of your uh intellectual
performance so i would just caution
anybody
against that kind of extreme
sleep habit in the justification of like
oh you'll sleep when you're dead hustle
hustle hustle i think that's really bs i
think it's really toxic i think that
sleep is something that you should
always prioritize and i also think that
this notion of like working out every
single day to the point that your hands
shake is just silly what are you
training for if you're trying to get
ripped you don't need that you know you
can do a lot of low intensity exercise
and just monitor your diet um
you know he's
burning 1400 calories in a single
workout um i assume he's
doing
uh you know he's burning roughly 5 500
calories a day so in addition to that
high intensity workout he'd also walk
that's a lot for a guy that looked like
he was relatively small you don't need
to do all that and i encourage you to
explore what high intensity feels like
you know like
maybe you've never gone that hard and
you've never worked out to you puked or
something like that it can be
interesting to explore that to know what
your upper limit is and
where you know that that failure uh is
as far as like resistance training or
where that intensity level is as far as
beats per minute on a heart rate that's
gonna make you throw up or make you
really uncomfortable but you don't need
to spend every workout doing that okay
this is an extreme version of that that
can actually like you can see it's not
good for your heart you're never gonna
recover and the sleep in addition to
that it just doesn't allow your body
uh to recover and over time that can be
deadly
so
chill out with it dude
there's there's
much safer ways to get ripped and have a
nice physique you do not need to kill
yourself in the process all right let's
let's just get a little bit of a lighter
note here okay let's do some cool stuff
i saw on the internet
what do otters sound like have you ever
wondered i'm about to answer that
question for you right now can we get
the volume cranking on that
turns out otters sound like this
do i love animals yes do i uh now follow
at least 20 otter pages because i
watched one otter video and loved it so
much and replayed it a bunch
would you have imagined huh and you know
when you see otters play too they play
like little dogs it's always fun it's
like oh of course because they're a
little like they're little river dogs
you know
wait christian do you like otters too
and apparently otters are rapists um i'm
just gonna throw that have you seen
michelle wolf special she like otters
will like
like they're super brutal to each other
now they look cute and of course you
know all animals have a potential to to
kill other animals have have you seen
this have you ever heard about this
or demonstrating pet me like this
oh you got it so cool and pet me bump oh
that's amazing
i really love stuff like that take your
hand see you take your hand
put it on hand
that is one of the cutest things i've
seen in a long time and it reminds me of
dolphins like the self-awareness of like
like dolphins know how to like mirror
things uh-huh
right yeah so these nasty little [ __ ]
all right and i want to show you this
because i'm always like if you're old
you got to do things like overhead press
and deadlift so this one is 82 years old
doing a 210 pound hex bar deadlift i
brought a kettlebell up to my mom that's
like 92 pounds and i encourage him like
dude get your do it like do a deadlift
like five times she can deadlift it and
it's just gonna help your spine it's
gonna help your lower back this is what
i aspire to people you know will
sometimes tell me like oh yeah you're
gonna get buffed now and you're on
steroids and but you know when you're
older it's all gonna go away and this
i'm like but it's not because i'm gonna
keep lifting you know and i'll have a
bionic shoulder at that point so
what's the next one there
making oh say the caption is me my haina
the gym ain't ever going to make you
money
but then it cuts to a male strip around
the ball
and that's true you know it's funny the
world of male stripping i remember
talking to this guy and like and also
i've seen a documentary but like
guys go to the strip club and it's like
i just want to see a hot girl i'm going
to throw money at her so she can like
flirt with me
when
women go to a male strip club like you
have to have this whole persona and like
fantasy scenario so that's why they do
like the fireman and the policeman and
like you know it's like a whole um
narrative that you want to have you know
like the lumberjack who's coming to like
build a cab you know so like it's not
just about they have to be buff and and
uh really good at what they do and be
good dancers i think maybe even more you
know demanding because they have to like
have a routine that's like you know they
bring the girl on stage and like you
know do everything with her and they
like have to like lift her up you know
what i mean it's like yeah the girl can
not take anything away from the the
difficulty of female stripping but you
know when a guy's on stage he has to
physically like hoist this girl up and
uh you know
make that part of the fantasy that he's
like manhandling you all that and each
one of these guys like develops their
whole thing like oh i come out as a
fireman and i'm do you know they have
like props and gimmicks and all that
stuff so i thought it was interesting
like
you know and you can make good money at
it but it's like
it seems like a real grind and after
that i was like nah you know like
if that ever if that thought ever went
into my head of like you know would it
be fun to be a male strip i'm like god
damn it seems like a lot of work
and uh and much more difficult to like
separate your like you know because
you're always thinking of like
you know
what you know
am i going to bring my uh you know
fire extinguisher on stage tonight
okay and
last but not least hella smart books you
know i read david goggins book recently
and i just wanted to pass it on to you i
think it fits well with this instagram
page
and i realized like not he's so popular
these days i realized like i'll be like
oh you've read david goggins book right
assuming like everybody's ready because
he's so popular but not a lot of people
have
it's an incredible story
um of triumph over difficult
circumstances because he was put through
so much
violence and trauma as a kid there's
this one crazy story where like you know
and in the audiobook
he has um you know
the
the guy who
uh wrote it with him they kind of do
like a podcast a mini podcast in between
chapters where they discuss the chapters
because some of the stuff he says so
outlandish that you almost have to like
ground it in reality like oh you
actually did this you did this like
24-hour race in hawaii that was like a
hundred miles and like it's on this like
insane uphill terrain and like people
you know like there's so many ways to
die doing it and you actually passed out
and like broke your feet and 10
different you know like he claims all
these things but it's like oh no you can
check the hospital records of whatever
he claimed and one of them was when he
was a kid
um
like he was in a school bus and
witnessed like this kid bringing a plate
of cookies because it was the last day
of school before christmas
up to the bus driver and he's like
running along and like trips and like
the school bus lurches forward and
splatters the kid head like a watermelon
and it sounds ridiculous like oh yeah of
course yeah sure you saw like a kid's
head explode under the wheel of a bus
but then like you know he verifies it
like oh no you can look in you know the
detroit newspaper whatever around that
time like this actually happened and um
that's just one of many things like he
watched like various parental figures
like his stepdad who like treated them
really well actually was like murdered
in front of him um
[Music]
he uh his his original father was super
abusive to both him and his mother and
there's all these different things that
he's overcome and i think you kind of
see that reflected in like the psychotic
nature of how he trains but
you know there's a number of incidents
in the book that are super inspirational
because
what it shows you is like there's just
no excuses and he's gone out and run
like an ultra marathon without any
training you don't mean he's like 240
pounds and like powerlifting and hasn't
done cardio in like you know a number of
years and is like i'm going to sign up
for this ultra marathon and like you
know by the last mile he's like [ __ ]
his pants his like feet are broken you
know he can't see straight he has to be
rushed to the hospital like you know
he's like
you know not only is like untrained but
did everything wrong he's like i know
i'm gonna eat like crackers and like
metric shakes and it was just like the
absolute worst nutrition you could put
in your body just as far as like you
know you're drinking they're drinking
water and gatorade and you're drinking
like this thick sludge and
um he's just put himself into a number
of things that require this extreme
mental fortitude that i think everybody
can be inspired by because we make so
many excuses for us i'm like oh i
couldn't do that i'm not i'm not in good
enough shape or it's too painful or
whatever he went through buds which is
the training for the navy seals like
three different times if you didn't make
it on the last one he would have been
permanently banned from trying buds
again but it was all because of injuries
you know like he like broke his kneecap
at one point but he's still like trying
to wrap it up and just do everything he
possibly could um
you know including engaging in mental
warfare with some of his instructors who
were like how to you know had a hard-on
for him and so he would like kind of he
he gives insight into how he looks at
the competition so to speak of like
whether he calls it taking souls so like
you know he finds little ways to like
you know get a mental advantage over the
people who were trying to destroy him
and i thought that was a really
interesting insight but um you know his
basic message if you know david goggins
is like quit being a [ __ ] you know quit
making excuses just go do it it doesn't
matter what anybody else says and i
relate to that a lot of times because
you know somebody who's really into
fitness or whatever there's always gonna
be somebody like oh
mark okay mr muscle man oh like even
that kind of stuff that's like
borderline supportive but also kind of
like mocking it's like you know his
message is like doesn't matter don't fit
in you don't need the approval of other
people you can just tell people to shut
up or put it out of your mind and go do
exactly what you want to do and don't
fear standing out in that positive way
of being exceptional even if it makes
other people uncomfortable and you know
if you are in a place where you need
some motivation if you need somebody to
be like hey quit being a [ __ ] pick up
that book and get it because he's going
to be
exactly what you need when we're talking
about um
that voice which sometimes you don't get
and i like to be supportive but
sometimes you just need to be told i
have that voice inside my own head
saying mark stopping a [ __ ] you know uh
take your shirt off right now to end the
episode and it's like all right no i'm
like i'm gonna keep it on like nobody
wants to see your packs and then it's
like no like one button at a time just
take it off like is this an 18 shirt
that was made in china that you ordered
online and we're concerned that it would
never come you know so you can afford to
manhattan a little bit and kind of just
take it off and even if this shirt gets
stuck on your sleeves you can say you
know what i found my own character here
comes mark to the stage it's a fitness
influencer oh yeah if you get in his
podcast he might make you famous
give it up for mark harley